[Musique]
le bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 28 mai un an après
nous prendrons des nouvelles de kevin et
guillaume taurin souvenez vous en mai
2018 les deux frères originaires des
yvelines se lancer dans un tour du monde
de trois ans un voyage à vélo de 80
mille kilomètres une conférence des
nations unies rejouer à guyancourt cette
simulation était proposée par une
association de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines 25 étudiants
répartis en deux commissions se sont
prêtés à l'exercice
et puis le 62e festival de cannes s'est
clôturé samedi avec le sacre de
parasites du sud coréen bong joon ho le
réalisateur franciliens la dgi a lui
reçu le prix du jury le débriefing de
cette édition avec les bills yvelinois
vincent mirabel spécialiste du cinéma
et puis nous parlerons également d'un un
grand concours culinaire organisé par le
groupe orpea dans toute la france la
présélection francilienne s'est tenue en
fin de semaine dernière et 1000 élèves
de saint quentin en yvelines pendant
deux jours qui ont participé au ski rops
et le challenge robotique qui a été
lancé hier au prisme à elancourt il
s'est achevé ce soir le thème de cette
quatrième édition robotique et cinéma et
dans le cadre de leur programme scolaire
les enfants de la maternelle au lycée
ont appris à programmer des petit robot
pour les faire évoluer sur un parcours
semé d'embûches de semé d'embûches
interview collectées par aurélien 11
il ya beaucoup de choses qui qui qui je
dirais qu'ils seront dans les sciences
du futur qui seront qui seront autour du
code du codage et dans l'utilisation des
robots donc c'est important que les
enfants comprennent comment ça
fonctionne s'intéressent à la chose tous
les outils numériques vont jouer un rôle
important
il faudra se faire l'écho des un codé
ses pensées comme disait steve jobs ce
donc
bien bien leur donner accès à ce savoir
faire à cette connaissance et cette
compétence qui va augmenter leur
employabilité et retrouver demain le
reportage complet sur ce 4ème ski robe
il ya tout juste un an les frères taurin
enfourché leur vélo pour débuter leur
tour du monde un voyage de trois ans 80
mille km et 45 pays à traverser une
aventure débutée au pied de la
cathédrale notre dame de paris avec
proches et amis aujourd'hui depuis le
chili
il dresse le bilan et mélanie poker
[Musique]
15000 km et 10 pays depuis un an
guillaume et kevin taurins sont sur les
routes les chemins les deux frères
yvelinois ont quitté la capitale 26 mai
2018 est la force dit que c'est passé
vite et en même temps s'est passé super
lentement ce qui s'est passé des
milliards et des milliards de choses on
a fait beaucoup de rencontres on à
parcourir énormément de km il ya eu
beaucoup de péripéties des bonnes comme
des mauvaises donc c'est vrai que c'est
une année très très riche dans votre
petite vie des péripéties malheureuse
comme le vol d'un vélo celui de
guillaume à lisbonne après seulement
3000 km de voyage mais aussi des
aventures inédites comme la traversée de
l'atlantique en bateau et des rencontres
qui chamboule leur programme on
s'organise plus de la même manière on
prévoit plus sur six mois mais vraiment
déjà si on sait ce qu'on fait dans un
mois c'est bien c'est ce qui est dur à
prendre en compte c'est la météo
et puis aussi les rencontres qu'on fait
sont par moments très très forte et qui
nous oblige à rester
enfin on se sent obligé de rester un peu
avec les personnes courent en compte
comme cette halte en argentine trois
semaines dans un village la grita avec
la rencontre d'un français michel et
voyez en faire tous les lacs la khomsa
junin de los andes lie à l'euro comme
volkan dany l'a vu en photo et à partir
de là tout est extraordinaire un voyage
penser à 2 mais rarement réalisé en duo
parfois rejoints par famille et amis
il roule aussi régulièrement avec
d'autres cyclistes depuis rio nous
sommes trop nous sommes accompagnés des
denis qui avait fait 5 jours avec nous
en partant de paris donc le 26 mai
dernier
on a aussi été accompagnés par un
brésilien qui a fait une journée toute
entière avec nous on a voyagé assise
pendant un mois
c'étaient tous des tourdumondiste tous
français notamment un qui vient de saint
germain est un breton et beaucoup de
bretons sur la route
dans un an les deux frères espère être
au nom des amériques leur voyage doit
encore durer deux ans des étudiants qui
se glisse dans la peau des représentants
des nations unies une simulation d'une
conférence de l'onu s'est tenue à
l'université versailles à 50 ans sur le
campus de guyancourt une première pour
l'établissement à l'initiative d'une
association étudiante elle le reportage
de marie lehn iapichino et de michael et
demi d'euros nous allons reprendre la
motion en cours donc qui porte sur la
répartition
des musiques climatique ce vendredi 24
mais l'heure est grave
un conseil de l'onu 100% étudiants se
réunit au sein de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
une simulation fictive organisé pour la
première fois dans la structure par
l'association sky moon c'est des sujets
qui sont extrêmement cohérent avec
l'actualité internationale et les pays
représentés sont représentés par des
étudiants qui doivent défendre leur
ligne politique tout en essayant de
trouver des accords communs pour
résoudre les problématiques qui sont
donnés au total 25 étudiants sont
répartis en deux commissions une en
langue et une en français tous ont
choisi un pays qu'ils doivent aux
représentés ils ont révisé pendant
plusieurs semaines pour défendre au
mieux leur politique extérieure pendant
la simulation
je pense que c'est important de le faire
aussi pour fernand se rendre compte de
la difficulté par exemple talent on a
fait une simulation de crise et au final
on n'a rien pu faire
tous les réfugiés sont morts donc je
pense que c'est important aussi pour se
rendre compte un peu de voix de la
difficulté de ce genre d'événement
l'occasion également de découvrir les
règles parfois très strictes de l'onu de
façon ludique le jeu et manille
même à l'onu c'est banni c'est des
sanctions qui peut passer par une
réduction du temps de parole
nouba ils doivent danser chanter et au
final ça rentre ça rend au regard du
succès rencontré cette année une
nouvelle session devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine dans les murs de l'ue
vs q cette motion est adoptée
c'est une alliance territoriales créées
dans la ville depuis deux ans trappe
territoire divan a été pensé par trois
membres fondateurs la municipalité
l'association en vie et le groupe auchan
aujourd'hui une dizaine de partenaires a
rejoint l'initiative entreprise
éducation nationale les associations
elles ont signé la charte de l'alliance
territoriale la semaine dernière au
cours d'une journée de restitution
attrape territoire vivant a pour
ambition de mettre en lien les acteurs
publics et privés avec les associations
pour faire face à des problématiques
locales comme l'emploi et l'insertion
professionnelle écoutez ses propos au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude le
but de l'alliance dans la première
partie de sa construction et son
évolution est très centré sur des
objectifs liés à l'insertion
professionnelle et notamment des jeunes
publics des jeunes de trappes
après l'alliance a vocation à évoluer de
manière plus générale sur d'autres
thématiques éventuellement sur la
mobilité
globalement l'idée c'est que comme
l'indiqué son nom à trappes territoire
vivant c'est que l'alliance apporte des
solutions mieux vivre des citoyens
trappistes la première chose prioritaire
que l'on a identifié c'est l'emploi donc
on axe nos forces là dessus pour le
démarrage et ça évoluera ensuite sur
d'autres aspects de la vie des citoyens
de trappes
quand on voit assis côte à côte et je
puis dire
proviseur de lycée un présent directeur
général d'une entreprise et les prises
andy l'association d'insertion le
le responsable
de l' agence pour l'emploi etc on se dit
que oui ce travail en équipe vos portes
et fessée mais nous vous en parlions
hier une marche pour le climat s'est
tenu pour la première fois à saint
quentin en yvelines l'initiative d'un
collectif et de 48 associations locales
elle nous vous annoncions hier ce
chiffre 300 participants étaient à la
marche samedi c'était un début de
manifestation
au final selon les organisateurs le
cortège a réuni plus de 600 personnes et
forces de l'ordre
elle annonce 450 manifestants un
concours de cuisine entre les chefs et
secondes et maisons de retraite il est
proposé en ce moment par le groupe orpea
qui est acteur de la prise en charge de
la dépendance
la onzième édition se déroule donc en ce
moment avec une présélection
francilienne qui a livré son verdict
vendredi dernier pour en parler et
jennyfer caron bon soir dans ça vous
êtes la directrice du village seniors
orpea de saint rémy les chevreuse et sur
ce site qui a été organisée à cette
présélection francilienne alors avant
d'en parler quelques mots déjà sur le
concours de présentation pourquoi
l'organiser quels sont les objectifs de
ce concours culinaire
on dirait que en fait la restauration
est une partie intégrante de notre
métier puisqu'aujourd'hui servir des
repas nos résidents patients et aussi à
leur famille qu'ils se joignent
volontiers régulièrement à leur table
c'est leur permettent de vivre un moment
de plaisir de convivialité qui est très
important pour eux au quotidien le repas
rythment les journées des personnes que
nous accueillons dans nos établissements
c'est un moment important pour eux on
est très attentifs à la présentation de
l'assiette à la qualité gustative et
aussi au dressage de la table qui
participent l'on va dire à ce moment de
convivialité notamment en avant la
créativité de ses chefs et aussi d'aider
second ça valorise aussi leur travail
pourquoi il faut le le valoriser ce
travail être chef peut-être dans ce
genre d'établissements médico social
c'est pas la même chose qu'être chef en
restaurant oui effectivement être être
chef dans la cuisine d'un n'est pas due
maison de retraite ou d'une clinique
c'est être chef en collectivité les
contraintes ne sont pas les mêmes que
dans un restaurant gastronomique nos
chefs sont soumis à de nombreuses
réglementations et doivent respecter de
nombreuses prostituées en termes de
qualité de sécurité et d'hygiène tout en
respectant l'équilibré alimentaire donne
aux résidents pour assurer leur
bien-être et le bien vieillir aussi à
des personnes accueillies chez nous donc
c'est la onzième édition de ce concours
mais c'était la première fois que le
site de saint rémy les chevreuse
accueillait une présélection
francilienne effectivement le site s'y
prête bien puisque le titre est un site
assez atypique avec de nombreux espaces
et infrastructures et nous avons ce qui
nous a permis d'accueillir effectivement
la finale francilienne dans nos locaux
ce qui toujours un plaisir aussi pour
nos résidents d'assister à cette finale
avec un thème cette année sur la terrine
du dimanche et le jury qui était
composée du maire de saint rémy
dominique bavoil qui est ancien
pâtissier il y avait également deux
chefs renommés qui sont donc le parisien
damien la porte et patrick kappler qui
est le chef du pavillon henri iv à saint
germain en laye c'est une chance vous
dites pour les résidents aussi pour les
candidats on imagine c'est une chance
pour pour nos chefs d'être évalués par
des professionnels alors effectivement
nous avons la chance d'avoir un maire
qui était un grand gastronomes et de par
son parcours professionnel et la chance
d'être jugé par des chefs qui ont
l'habitude de travailler des produits
nobles aussi est d'avoir le souci du
détail de l'assiette au quotidien mais
comment les candidats ont-ils été
départagés commence à céder mais là on
avait des avions une note
sur plusieurs items donc la créativité
le dressage de l'assiette
et puis bien sûr la qualité gustative et
donc et le respect des consignes données
qui est effectivement une terrine du
dimanche approprié pour être servi dans
un restaurant et vainqueur si je puis
dire c'est le local de l'étape steve
ramon hayes qui n'est autre que le chef
de cuisine du village seniors orpea de
saint rémy les chevreuse oui
effectivement c'est notre chef cette
année qui a remporté la demi-finale et
qu'il y aura la chance d'aller en finale
en novembre seront en région parisienne
la finale nationale s'organisera en
région parisienne en novembre
donc on imagine fierté pour le site de
saint-rémy que ça soit le chef
finalement de de ce site qui aille à
cette finale nationale
ah oui une somme très fiers de notre
chef qui de toute façon au quotidien
s'efforcent de satisfaire nos résidents
et qui a fait preuve encore une fois
lors de ce trophée de sa créativité au
travers de cette assiette
il nous reste 30 secondes juste un petit
mot de présentation sur le site orpea de
cinq minutes alors le site orpea est un
site assez exceptionnel il est le seul
et unique concept en france il regroupe
sur huit hectares en vallée de chevreuse
une résidence service un ehpad une
clinique
nous avons aussi une crèche à
destination des enfants du personnel et
une école d'aide-soignante et nous avons
la chance d'avoir de nombreuses
fractures comme aussi une piscine une
salle de spectacle et des autres
infrastructures type fitness et autres
mais je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice de ce village seniors pea de
saint rémy les chevreuse merci denis
fort car on a d'être passé sur ce
plateau
l'assurance maladie elle lance une
campagne pour inciter les yvelines on a
créé leur dossier médical partagé ce
carnet de santé dématérialisée permet de
simplifier les transmissions des
informations médicales
l'objectif c'est une meilleure
coordination des soins mode d'emploi
avec aurélie rond et marylène yapi
chinois
et donc là la carte s'est assuré est en
train de créer son dossier médical
partagé ce carnet de santé numérique
existe depuis octobre 2018 dans les
yvelines
il permet de regrouper toutes les
données d'un patient comme les
pathologies les allergies éventuelles ou
l'historique des soins on évite de vous
faire des examens qui aurait par exemple
déjà été fait ou au contraire on a des
résultats plus anciens donc on sait
qu'il faut agir peut-être refaire un
nouveau contrôle de tel ou tel examen
avantage de ce dossier médical partagé
pour les professionnels de santé un gain
de temps et une meilleure prise en
charge des patients la possibilité
d'avoir accès à un certain nombre de
données notamment des données
biologiques permet aux pharmaciens
d'adapter la posologie ou vérifier la
cohérence entre la posologie et les
certains médicaments et les données
biologiques du patient notamment chez le
personnage cela personnages et quelques
minutes suffisent pour créer son dmp sur
le site internet dans un point d'accueil
assurance maladie ou bien en pharmacie
toutes les données sont confidentielles
et sécurisé vous garder totalement la
main sur le contenu de votre dossier
médical partagé donc le professionnel de
santé pour accéder au dossier médical a
besoin de votre accord et surtout de sa
carte de professionnel de santé
le stockage des données qui v qui est
assurée par un hébergeur extérieur qui a
été homologué par le ministère de la
santé
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines plus de 95
mille personnes ont ouvert leur dossier
médical partagé mais vous l'avez suivi
dans ce journal la semaine dernière nous
vous faisions à vivre le festival de
cannes au travers des yvelinois présents
sur place l'événement cinéma s'est
clôturé samedi et pour cause d'élections
européennes c'est ce soir seulement que
nous à débris font ce rendez vous avec
un ebe noah justement qui était à ce 72e
festival c'est vous vincent mirabel mon
soir bonsoir
alors vous êtes spécialiste de cinéma
vous enseignez notamment à 3 yes l'école
troisième ce qui est implantée à
elancourt vous êtes l'auteur de nombreux
ouvrages sur le sujet dont sur le cinéma
dont l'histoire du cinéma pour les nuls
qui est aux éditions first
alors sur place pendant toute la
quinzaine vous avez été sur place
pendant toute la quinzaine du festival
vous avez vu une
trentaine de films déjà votre impression
générale sur la 72e édition vous la
placez ou par rapport aux autres
éditions de la place assez haut
j'ai trouvé que ce 62e festival était à
l'image de la fiche réussi consensuelle
une affiche avec agnès varda voilà agnès
varda qui fait un peu l'écho entre ceux
qui osent inventé et puis ceux qui
aiment faire rêver donc une affiche dans
l'état orange avec agnès varda vraiment
novice magnifique réalisation
par ailleurs la conscience surréalité se
voit par rapport à la sélection mais
également par rapport au clam mares et
de ce côté là c'est réussi
là on va dresser le bilan de ce palmarès
dans un instant quand on est sur place
en tant que spécialiste du cinéma ça
ressemble à quoi une quinzaine au
festival de cannes alors là je veux vous
dire c'est la folie c'est vraiment un
marathon je récupère depuis 48 heures
tellement on court grosso modo on se
lève à 6h du matin pour pouvoir être
dans une file d'attenté 7h et accrocher
un premier film à 8h 8h30 ça pour que ce
soit possible de voir une trentaine de
films
il faut faire ses fils d'amis 30 j'ai
même croisé des cinéphiles qu'envoyer 40
à 50
là c'est de la gourmandise mais
l'important c'est de voir les films
vraiment important et qui compte et vous
avez animé aussi des leçons de cinéma
sur wii j'ai eu cette chance de
d'intervenir auprès du jury oecuménique
pour donner en fait quelques clés
d'audiovisuel et ce qui m'a fait très
plaisir
en croisant tous ceux qui étaient
présents lors de cette leçon c'est de
voir à quel point il me signalait que
tout ce qu'ils voyaient après cette
leçon
eh bien il le comprenait mieux et il me
disait vincent ce que j'ai vu est ce que
tu nous a dit ça marche si on vient sur
le port le palmarès le 62e édition qui a
vu le sacre du sud coréen bong joon ho
avec parasites donc lauréat de la palme
d'or c'est un drame familial qui dépeint
les inégalités sociales en corée du sud
c'est une première palme d'or pour un
film sud coréen est ce que c'est mérité
totalement méritée alors pour une fois
le jury n'a pas fait compliqué quand ils
pouvaient faire simple il est allé droit
sur un film qui m'a vraiment et tout
public
on a à faire un casting parfait
un scénario bien ficelé et une mise en
scène réussie donc parasite a vraiment
fait pas l'unanimité parce qu'à caen
c'est impossible de faire les limiter
mais en tout cas c'était une palme qui
ne prête pas à des railleries
il est largement au dessus d'un autre
film qui avait été longtemps tenu pour
le futur lauréat à savoir douleur et
gloire danois devraient beaucoup en
effet leur leurs favoris sont favoris
dont les règles voir le film d'almodovar
qui est une sorte d'autobiographie qui
revient sur la vie du réalisateur
espagnol complètement autobiographique
est certainement très thérapeutique
moi je pense que c'est un film très
important pour pedro almodovar mais
néanmoins
on est très loin du niveau de parle avec
elle ou tout sur ma mère
la réalisation est relativement plate
donc personnellement je n'avais vraiment
pas accroché à ce film et je n'étais pas
le seul
et sur ce film ya le prix
d'interprétation masculine qui a été
obtenu par antonio banderas qui joue le
héros de ce fier pleinement mérité qu'il
a pleinement mérité
oui parce que il joue le rôle de
quelqu'un de dépressif et qui souffrent
physiquement dans son corps et ça c'est
un rôle vraiment difficile pour le
rendre intéressant et crédible or
banderas est parfaitement crédible donc
bravo pour ce choix du jury également si
on revient aussi sur ce festival l'un
des événements de cette croisée de
c'était la présence de quentin tarantino
leonardo dicaprio et brad pitt pour once
upon a time in hollywood là ou s'il n'y
avait pas de motif de rivaliser avec le
film sud coréen ou alors écoutez je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de pouvoir voir ce
film tellement il y avait de monde en
fait seulement deux séances d'organiser
ça a été la folie la fébrilité deux
jours avant on se sentait granderson
essayant d'avoir des places pour être
sûr de rentrer même la presse a été
souvent de laboulaye
c'était très très très difficile et je
crois que les échos aux segments sont
très partagés aussi par rapport à ce
film donc en tout cas parasite a mis
tout le monde d'accord sauf évidemment
l'équipe de faire un tonneau pour une
fois qui repart bredouille alors pour tv
78 nous avions suivi particulièrement
plus particulièrement certains des films
soutenus par la région ile de france il
y en avait 16 au total en sélection
officielle mais aussi dans les
différentes sélections parallèles du
festival
deux ont été récompensés meilleur
scénario pour portrait de la jeune fille
en feu de céline sciamma et le prix du
jury en ex-aequo c'est pour le film du
francilien la dgi les misérables c'est
une plongée dans la réalité la banlieue
parisienne
et c'est un film qui a fait sensation
sur la croisette c'était le cas pour
vous il a été projeté très tôt dans les
premiers jours et ça buzz est vraiment
dans le bon sens il faut reconnaître à
ce film de grande qualité
d'abord les acteurs sont très crédibles
et ont fait une plongée dans la banlieue
difficile du côté de montfermeil là d'où
est originaire la geely
et on al'impression fait d'assister à la
haine trente ans après a été réalisé par
matthew goss villematier séquence avicii
en chine qui a marqué le cinéma français
les misérables va probablement marquer
mais il inquiète aussi parce qu'il
montre que la situation dans les
banlieues c'est terriblement dégradée
on est parfois dans des zones de conflit
des scènes de guerre la police n'est pas
exempt de reproches mais à la fois de
temps en temps certains policiers font
du mieux possible
on voit que les jeunes sont maintenant
acteurs générer des conflits
c'est inquiétant et on voit en tout cas
un gap par rapport à la n 10 à 30 ans
mais les misérables a de grandes
qualités et il faut voir ce film alors
très rapidement il nous reste moins de
30 secondes
ce coup de coeur on l'a compris pour
vous il y en a un autre qui était dans
la quinzaine des réalisateurs présents
dans le film étonnant figurez vous que
j'ai assisté à une conférence de presse
sur scène il y avait un frigidaire un
frigidaire intelligents capables en fait
d'améliorer la vie d'un musicien rap un
peu looser et ce film s'appelle yves en
anglais le titre et sa bru puisque ces
all bat yves caumon lien avec le fameux
film de mankiewicz
moi j'ai trouvé ça très créatif avec un
scénario bien maîtrisé ça fait plaisir
de voir des films français comme ça
qu'ils ont été qui permettent de révéler
en fait de bons réalisateurs et la
casanet exactement c'est pour ça et tous
ces films seront à découvrir bien sûr en
salle ou le sont déjà 1 puisqu'ils sont
déjà sortis merci vincent mirabel est
d'être passé sur ce plateau yvelinois
spécialiste du cinéma et auteur de
nombreux ouvrages sur le sujet je
rappelle le plus connu l'histoire du
cinéma pour les nuls un livre illustré
et réédité c'est toujours aux éditions
first
j'ajoute que notre compilation de
reportages réalisés à cannes pour tv 78
seront rediffusés 1 dans l'émission 7 8
dossiers ça sera à diffuser à partir de
vendredi sur notre antenne invité les
élèves et professeurs de deux écoles à
se rencontrer tous les deux ans et
l'encours propose courants d'art c'est
un festival autour des arts plastiques
et de la danse la dernière édition
elle se tenait samedi à la ferme du
mousseau une invitation cette année à
une balade en forêt patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poker
on fait des araignées des élections et
c'est avec de l'argile les petites bêtes
ont envahi la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt ont fêté la nature et la forêt
le thème du 8e festival courants d'art
l'idée c'est avec les enfants de
réaliser tous ces animaux en argile ou
avec des éléments qu ont accueilli ce
matin avec les enfants pour voir la
créer on s'est rendu compte que c'était
vraiment un sujet d'actualité qu'en
termes scientifiques
il y avait beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes mais aussi en termes
poétiques
la forêt c'est un c'est un lieu de
l'imaginaire c'est c'est le lieu du
grand méchant loup de l'ogre de la belle
au bois dormant et c'est un lieu voilà
qui parle à toutes les générations
des ateliers de création des expositions
et des performances
le festival est organisé tous les deux
ans par les écoles de la ville
elle prépare et créé en commun l'idée
c'est vraiment le travail
transdisciplinaire c'est à dire faire se
rencontrer les disciplines et faire
pratiquer ensemble des gens issus de
disciplines différentes c'est proposer
aux danseurs de pratiquer les arts
plastiques s'est proposé aux plasticiens
de découvrir la danse pour cette 8e
édition une plasticienne chorégraphe et
les itinéraires poétiques ont été
associés mélanie poké désormais avec moi
pour son coup de coeur culture bonsoir
on s'est revus alors pour ceux qui ont
la chance de profiter de leurs vendredi
un long week-end de quatre jours les
attend l'occasion de profiter de
nombreux rendez vous culturel que
propose le territoire il y aura encore
mélanie un choix à faire
comme toujours mais il ya surtout pour
tous les goûts les amoureux de cinéma de
musique de théâtre vont être servis car
ce week-end débute un des grands rendez
vous culturels de la ville de versailles
c'est le mois molière c'est la 24e
édition et comme chaque année un mois de
théâtre mais aussi de musique de
conférences dans la cité royale de
nombreuses créations dès le début du
festival puisque les 1er 2 juin la
grande écurie accueil accompagné de
l'éternel était elle est en résidence
elle jouera le capitaine fracasse
d'après théophile gautier le dramaturge
français est aussi à l'honneur
pourrait aussi des ainsi découvrir vous
découvrez des pieds amoureux les
fourberies de scapin les fâche
difficile bien sûr de tout donné donc le
plus simple c'est de se rendre sur le
site du festival qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran à rambouillet c'est un
anniversaire qui est célébrée celui d'un
fameux festival woodstock tout
simplement
il a 50 ans du 15 au 18 18 août 2008
1969 près d'un demi million de
spectateurs sont rassemblé 32 groupes se
succèdent sur trois jours et demi avec
du folk du blues du rock et de la soul
je vous éviterez les noms en bien sûr
c'est tous très connu pour cet
anniversaire c'est l'usiné à chapeaux
qui prévoit plusieurs jours de fête on
va les voir s'afficher à l'écran ça
débute ce vendredi qu'une conférence
elle sera présentée par henri chartier
spécialiste de musique actuelle et de la
chanson française
il reviendra sur les temps forts de
l'événement et surtout ses répercussions
mais pour cet événement les groupes des
studios de l' usine à chapeaux seront
aussi à l'honneur
et oui les équipes demande au public de
se parer de ses plus belles chemises à
fleurs et pantalons pattes d'eph pour le
concert du 1er juin qui débute à 20h
plus actuelles pour terminer amel bent
sera sur la scène aux mureaux eh oui la
chanteuse française revient après quatre
ans d'absence elle démarre sa tournée le
1er juin et pour le concert des mureaux
il ne faudra pas beaucoup plus patiente
et puisqu'elle chantera ce dimanche de
juin elle défendra notamment son nouvel
album demain et bien sûr interprétera
ses plus grands succès mais votre plus
grand succès avoue mélanie c'est le 7-8
culture et vous l'interprétez dans un
instant juste après ce journal le
journal qui touche à sa fin un belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]